what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a fresh and fit
podcast clip before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel as
you guys know i'm trying to get to 20
000 subscribers
so each and every one of you helps while
you're at it ring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily
videos okay
who's responsible
hello i get what you're saying but take
away birth control take away
condoms what's gonna happen you go sleep
with another guy and you're gonna have
his kid
so you can't put the same type of like
requirements on men as you can of women
yeah for us sex is very physical it's
not it's not the same the same thing
like
because guys get girls pregnant outside
their relationship
you know and we have to deal with that
right whose fault is it though yeah
who's that what is it if a woman is
pregnant has a child or whatever it's
100 her fault she can choose to keep it
enough
more controversial no it's it is her
fault but it's his fault
too and that's what he always negates
the consequences
like for like four minutes hold on you
should have pulled out
okay i feel like it's definitely both
that's on the guy too
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah it's
definitely ball no hold on
[Laughter]
oh my gosh because we had this
discussion before yeah uh on another
show if you had a million dollars
right actually let me let me switch it
up for all the ladies in here
let's say i have a million dollars right
you have no access to spend it though
but it's both of our million dollars
you can't spend it only i can and i
spend it i buy hookers
blow buy a corvette here take another
girl on a trip here buy a bunch of bags
shopping spree whatever
and i run out and run out of money and i
come back and say hey what the [ __ ]
we're out of money this is your fault
are you responsible for that
when you had no access to the money no
no no
but no but that's not a good way to like
yeah
no yes okay so okay you're still
responsible for the for the millionaires
yes it's our money right
okay did i advise you
she's funny okay then no okay no
no miss venezuela no but that wasn't a
good analogy
i'm gonna explain why it's a good
analogy right now ladies you ready
women have a hundred percent monopoly on
who gets born and who gets aborted
if i want to have the kid and you're
pregnant i can't tell you to have the
kid
you say [ __ ] you i'm not having a kid
and abort the child and vice versa if
you want to have it can i say abort it
i have no say in it so you cannot give
anyone responsibility
when they don't have authority i'm gonna
say that again because a lot of women
don't like hearing this
[Music]
you can't give someone responsibility
when they had zero authority
you have a hundred percent authority but
the guy has a hundred percent authority
over who he sleeps with so he's trying
to negate
the issue of the man
cheating and getting another girl
pregnant and i'm not i'm not here to say
like
i think men should have more of a say in
that stuff than they do like i'm 100
with him on that point
but he's trying to act like the man
doesn't have any responsibility from
what i'm understanding
he's born in the united states i have
zero therefore
you are responsible not the man and i
know you guys don't like hearing that
because it takes two to tango
but which states that you can't even
have abortions yeah in countries as well
yeah also it's our bodies so [ __ ] and
then you're here
and then your body has to go thank you
your body your children your body your
choice like it's your body that you put
your dick
in the girl and could have pulled out
you could have pulled up
once again let's go see i'm kind of in
between because
i understand what he's saying that like
women have 100 control over who's born i
agree with that point
but at the same time
like you have a hundred percent control
over who you sleep with and the problems
that come with that
so to act like he doesn't have a say
who chooses who has sex two people both
no no no but you choose who you pursue
this is such a bad analogy let me choose
who has sex and who does not if both
parties had
you know an equal opportunity to get sex
we wouldn't have 80 percent of men
sexist right now women have 100 monopoly
on who has sex
and who's born and who's not in the
united states and on top of that you're
saying some states don't allow abortion
you could drive over to another state
most states united states allow for
abortion
and i have no say-so you said pro-choice
agreed which means pro-responsibility as
well
i have no choice so you cannot make me
responsible it is a woman's fault
if she has a child or aborts a period
there's a nice question
it's a woman it's your fault if you get
a girl pregnant
right there's a quote that's going on
right now that says can't we just agree
it's the man's fault if he knocks up a
girl
and it's the girl's fault if she gets
knocked up
with who they want man with who they can
because think about it it's your body so
i can't force you and if i do it's
you know but that's not 100 true because
there are guys that have
options that choose to wait until
they're married to have sex you see it
in the church all the time
so i mean i understand like they're
talking about in general in society
that's totally a fair point but
part of taking individual responsibility
is taking the responsibility
responsibility that if you knock a girl
up that's your own fault
like illegal no problem i don't know i
just sorry quick question though no no
no no you already had two
answers yeah does that mean the man
still taking responsibility for the kid
though
if she just choose like would you take
responsibility because you did have sex
with you have pro-choice with your body
your choice my wallet my choice you
cannot
force the man to pay obviously we have
legal conventions
that allow for that okay but that's see
here's the thing
women want to have control right
and opportunity but they don't want to
deal with the responsibility if it's
pro-choice pro-body
then you have to deal with the
consequences that come from that
honestly
i wouldn't be opposed to having some
sort of
like fairness where men have to sign off
on abortions too i wouldn't be
completely
opposed i haven't really thought through
like how that would work
um if that's the argument that he's
making but to
act like in any way shape or form it's
the right thing to do
to not be in a child's life that's
i mean any anyone with common sense
knows
that if you knock somebody up that's
your own deal if man doesn't want to pay
that's your fault for selecting a man
that wasn't equipped to be a father
that's true that's a hundred percent
true it's it's your fault
who you choose to sleep with i'm i'm
with him on that women choose who they
[ __ ]
men [ __ ] who they can that's the
difference and guess what
if he didn't pull out just a morning
after pill yeah
exactly like but maybe you don't know
and then maybe there's there's
think the guy should pay for the
aftermath i'll say this
yeah again if the man doesn't have to
pay for anything because you're the one
who
who picks he should i personally i think
he should
yeah what as a guy you should pay for
that pill bro just get out of the way
yeah
but not every guy but here's the thing
once again ladies accountability has to
go back on you
you choose who you have sex with you
pick who you ejaculate in you without a
condom
you pick yeah so therefore i agree
with the consequences that come from
your decisions you can't have
you know pro-choice sexual freedom all
this other stuff without responsibility
so that's the way it is i mean if you
guys don't so that's why i use that
analogy with a million dollars all right
go ahead you'll go
but i just okay this is a weird um
analysis of the social situation i don't
know why but he just comes off as very
like
fake confident to me i don't know why
i can't describe why i feel this way
it's just how i feel
but i feel like women can pick this
stuff out like we could smell
fake confidence that the men also choose
not to have sex with a condom
even though like obviously if i can't
put it inside you if you don't let me
who has the final right of refusal
i can rape you disclaimer
okay in that case let's not use that
word
call it great yeah
but yeah there's conventions there to
protect you from that you know what i'm
saying there's
like you know you can get an abortion
without any type of consequence whatever
may be so there's conventions that
and i don't mean to be an [ __ ] but
that's a very that's an exception to the
rule
most of the time it's consensual sex
let's keep it a stack yeah so
uh yeah so yeah you still have first
they can't bang you without your
you know without your consent what if
you want to breaks
okay we'll get to your question next
what's your name
okay um yeah that was an interesting
back and forth with the women um i'm not
against like having more
systems in place that maybe protect like
men's rights in terms of like
um what like with children and stuff
like that's i'm totally fine with
something like that as a proposed
solution but
to take all accountability off of men
just because abortion is legal
like to me not a good argument but let
me know in the comments if you guys
agree or disagree do not forget to ring
the notification
bell and subscribe to the channel i'll
talk to you guys next time